Dave good morning how are you
Corrin dad how you doing doing okay how
long you been covering the Patriots so
this is my fourth season I did the first
three of them 2006 to 2008 what is the
goal going into a press conference with
Bill Belichick for you well the the goal
was going into a press conference with
Bill's the same as it is with anybody
it's you know to to get information I
realized it's a little bit tougher with
him because he's less he's less is more
reluctant to give that information but
you know there's no there's no
particular agenda other than there are
questions that need to be answered and
maybe I just have to take a different
approach to get something out of him
than I might have to take somebody else
have you heard from the Patriots or
Belichick individually about the
questions you've asked no no and and you
know I wouldn't go so far as to say that
it's not like I'm the only person asking
a difficult question or or pursuing you
know it's just this is sort of we've
just gotten into these couple of
exchanges here that have just I guess
got a little more attention than some
others do let's go back to the Garoppolo
question this is what a month ago when
you talked about if Garoppolo was
successful
what happens if Brady comes back a seat
and play that exchange then we'll talk
to Dave about it look I told you what's
going to happen
what happened after that day what
happened after he said Jesus Christ yeah
well I mean um in what sense you mean
outside of the newsroom or no was there
a follow-up did he did he just okay no
that was that was I think bill pretty
much closed the topic response I
remember feeling like I remember that
the first thought I had was okay I can
quote that but but you know leading into
that question okay I heard you guys
discussing it yesterday it was sort of
an emotional roller coaster where there
was a guy asking good questions and
there was a guy asking the stupid
question and then he was the same guy in
the big twist at the end but that
question you you actually and most clips
do cut out the first part the way I
started that question was I asked him if
he had ever named a week five starter
during the month of July okay because
the context surrounding this question is
that the last 15 years the Patriots have
told us that every job is up for grabs
that your past performance is irrelevant
and the person that plays better is
going to start and to some degree when
Jimmy Garoppolo plays four games he's
not filling in he's auditioning so I
wanted to get something on the record
beyond what bill had said in the
preamble to his press conference two
days before which was that Tom would
take over okay tom is coming back is
that unconditional if Jimmy plays it has
an extraordinary couple of games is that
is a position under review well as it
turns out that's a pretty relevant
question right now and I think Bill's
probably happier to have had something
like what he has now on the record in
July as opposed to having to answer that
question when Tom comes back because
believe me he would have well I can't I
give you credit for asking the pertinent
question about Agora PLO's injury but
there's there's no what you know deep
down there's no way that Tom Brady is
going to be losing his job to Jimmy
Garoppolo even if Garoppolo is perfect
has a perfect quarterback rating through
four games he's just not well in July of
last year we knew there was no chance
Brock
while I was gonna play last year wait
how does Brock Osweiler get involved in
this because here's the thing okay first
of all you have to remember that when I
asked this question this was before that
anyone had taken a snap in camp okay or
at least what bill said it was a day
before anyone had taken a snap in camp
he hadn't been evaluated yet and tom
brady's 39 years old now look he'll
probably play only 50 okay but when it
goes for him just like for everybody
else it will go quickly he will be a
Hall of Famer one day and then one day
he won't be okay and then we're going to
have an issue that's that this kind of
discussion arises out of and again Bill
Belichick has told us for a decade and a
half that every job is under review so
yes when he is changing that policy and
assigning someone a week five job even
if it is Tom Brady I'm gonna I'm gonna
be curious and say wait a minute this
isn't how you've done things since you
got here why is it different now yeah
but if the answer is because Tom Brady's
great fine I just want a billion but
Brady is not injured he didn't have a
devastating injury he didn't struggle
peyton manning's struggle peyton manning
didn't deserve to be out there he opened
the draft for Bako sweater Oh Brady -
yeah it's it's completely different Dave
I I you could question that the Broncos
about Peyton Manning - wait a minute not
done tom bray you're evaluating you're
evaluating something that hadn't
happened yet with Brady we didn't know
what Brady was going to be in camp and
that's what I'm getting at okay what if
what if Jimmy had a better camp than Tom
and then went out and played well so
you're you're penciling in Brady for
week five you're telling us before he
takes a snap in camp that he is still
Tom Brady Hall of Fame quarterback okay
he's made everyone else prove that
they're the right person for the job in
every single circumstance until this
moment so yes I was going to ask because
it was a change from it was it was a
deviation from the norm who starts
tonight by the way you know I mean the
Patriots have like this legacy of magic
tricks so we're told that Jimmy doubtful
we're told that he can't lift his arm
over his head and you know part of me
all the information suggests that
Jacobi's gonna play but i mean how do
you how do you sit here and say they're
never going to know they're not going to
pull a rabbit out of their hat tonight
and then there's Jimmy starting playing
well yeah it's the Patriots way but it
feels like it's brusett but I hear you I
got all the information to suggest its
percent yeah
well Dave thanks you're good sport keep
stirring it up thanks for joining us
enjoy the game tonight all right Dave
Brown Concord Monitor Patriots reporter
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience